- Sure, everybody is mostly talking about
how warm we all are, however, we'd like
to talk about how warm things can get.
Do you guys know the meaning of the term
"Netflix & Chill"?
- This is a great segue by the
way, that was a great segue.
- Netflix & Chill, I do
that almost every night,
you just literally get your
popcorn, get your tacos
and you lay down and you just chill.
- Maybe like watch stream
binge-watch some TV show
on Netflix and take off our
clothes in the air conditioning.
- Netflix & Chill means
we're gonna watch the TV but we're not.
- What are we gonna do?
- Fingering.
- That's what we did, my mother and I
and my children and my wife, wing up
Netflix and we chill, so
that's all we do in our house
is watch Netflix and chill.
- However, kids today
are changing the meaning
of Netflix & Chill, and
now it's an invitation
to sort of hook up, like
you wanna come over and
Netflix & Chill.
- Oh, no, no, that don't mean
- Netflix & Chill, I
would assume you stick
something on Netflix and just chill.
It wasn't one of the trickier conundrums,
you don't need the guy
from The Imitation Game
to solve that one.
- What does that mean?
It means you're a freak.
- Really, people wanna hook up when they
watch Orange is the New Black?
- You watch Netflix with
the air conditioning on.
- Basically it means
when a man loves a woman
and they equally love
Netflix, they get together
and magic happens.
- I mean it's come over and fuck.
- She nailed it.
- How does that make you feel?
- Picturing kids hook
up? Great. I love it.
- these kids and their sex.
- They're all so horny.
- Everyone's horny.
- No, the kids are though, especially
- Not me, I got my horny gland removed.
- You got it removed?
I think that's called
your penis.
- No, it's a gland.
- Can you give me the name of your guy?
- Penile removal dot com.
- I got Netflix Chill with
myself last night. I did.
- Oh, I got Netflix Chill
big time with myself.
- Oh, my.
- If you could Netflix
& Chill with anybody,
who would you choose?
- You? (laughs)
- Jack Nicholson
- I feel that that'd
be the most terrifying
chilling ever.
- Are you serious?
That's like the dream.
- Is anyone ever got just
lost in your eyes before?
Does anyone tell you that?
- I've been told they look
like pools in the ocean, but
- They're beautiful.
- You've gotta quit.
- I've just never seen it up close.
- You've gotta stop.
- No, you've gotta stop.
- This ends one way,
don't write a check that you can't cash.
- I'm ready.
- 'Cause I will, right,
- I'm just
- Your office is right round
the corner from my office.
It's already dangerous.
- I'm just saying if we start something,
maybe we could finish it.
- How can I quit you?
- I'll never be able to quit you.
That was beautiful.